the height may have subsided but attack
on Titan was Bar None the biggest thing
in the anime world just a few years ago
taking a break from the usual themes of
friendship power protagonist plot armor
and fanservice that's been running
rampant in typical anime during that
time attack on titan instead built
itself on subverting all of those in
this video we'll take a look at some
titles that are similar to attack on
Titan those that share some themes and
elements with that series and could
temporarily quench your craving for more
attack on Titan while you await its
inevitable next installment number 10 we
have Carbonari of the iron fortress
among the anime on this list this may be
the most obvious inclusion in this anime
the worlds in the midst of an industrial
revolution when a mysterious virus
appears and transforms people into
carbonate and dead creatures that can't
be destroyed through conventional means
the only way to kill these monsters is
to pierce their steel coated hearts
instead of falling into the ranks of
these monsters ecomo resists infection
and becomes a Carbonari a human carbon a
hybrid taking a step further from other
shows on the list with its similar
premise carbon era of the iron fortress
even looks like attack on Titan come on
take a look at the post through the
overall ambience of the whole thing the
only reason is didn't make it to number
one on the list by a landslide is
because the shows are ranked by my
perceived overall quality not by their
similarities to attack on Titan
shooting its way to the nine spot is
black bullets the years 2021 and mankind
finds itself devastated by gastrea a
parasitic virus capable of infecting
humans and animals turning them into
monsters hopeless against this sort of
zombie apocalypse humans are forced to
hide inside cities protected by monolith
walls fortified with the only material
that can hurt gastrea miranium enter
rentaro Satomi a team who lost his
parents in the gastrea war
partnered with a new and energetic and
clingy little girl with trust issues the
two aim to protect Tokyo from the
gastrea threat black bullet may or may
not be inspired by attack on titan
setting but the similarities are far too
obvious this time we've got humanity
hiding behind walls against monstrous
threats that can affect and take over
people with the premise of humanity's
hope lying on special groups of people
trained to deal with the imminent threat
telling us you're going
both of their stings arisen at number
eight we have God Eater in 2071 the
world as we know it was destroyed by
creatures known as origami immune to
conventional weaponry the are gommi run
wild and humanity was driven to near
extinction
however hope is not lost an organisation
managed to develop God ogz weapons that
are capable of defeating the unstoppable
monstrosities their wield is accorded
God eaters God it is the first of many
shows that have a lot of similarities to
attack on Titan the setting for both
shows is a dystopian world where
humanity's being driven to extinction by
unbeatable monsters only for the humans
to discover or develop a specific way to
combat them I would say that the two
series different in a lot of ways though
for one good eaters world places more
emphasis on technology and a modernized
world nevertheless if you want a
slightly different take on the attack on
Titan formula you can always check this
show
with the decisive swing seventh on the
list is a comedic ill skilled fighter
Tatsumi embarks on a quest to the
capital in order to earn money for his
impoverished village he soon gets
involved in an attack by the assassin
group night trade witnessing firsthand
the rampant corruption in the capital
and even nearly becoming a victim
himself he ends up as the newest member
of night raid a group that in reality
intends to cleanse the capital of
corruption finally we take a much-needed
break from all the humanity getting
wiped out by a virus / monster invasion
and turtling up in fear and tiller
unlikely hero takes their first step
stories its similarities to attack on
tides income in its graphic nature and
willingness to kill off main characters
regardless of plot importance key
characters aren't safe resulting in
uncertainty and suspense deaths are
final in this gritty Shonen Series and
sure enough many people who like to
attack on Titan ended up liking elements
in a car mega kill when it aired up next
is vampire fantasy Sarah of the end just
like what those debunked prophecy said
the whole world in this anime does come
to an end in 2012 doomsday comes in the
form of a virus that eliminates everyone
age 13 and above the remnants of
humanity become enslaved to the world's
new conquerors vampires the surviving
children were easily subdued and made
into livestock by the new vampire
overlords growing tired of this life
Yuichiro and Michaela hatched a plan to
escape from the vampires once again we
have a premise that's similar to attack
on titan people fighting a war for
survival against monstrous beings that
toppled humanity's previous place in the
world's order seems to be quite a
popular theme in this case we even have
a protagonist that's eerily similar to
Eren in personality and motivations
unfortunately the tense survival
thriller atmosphere went after a while
we're then left with something that's
more comparable to a shounen jump series
with a plethora of elements from Sharman
King and bleach as well as a lot of
fujiyoshi bait
Sekai Oh Kyra Schneider she's not still
da ya da da
fifth on this list is the inspirational
favorite gurren lagaan in a future where
the spiral King rules the world humans
are forced to live inside underground
villages one of the people who lives in
such villages discovers a drill shaped
key that allows him to activate a robot
that brings him and his foster brother
governor to the surface where they're
introduced to the world above and an
enemy mecha called gunmen and so a whole
new journey begins yes this series an
attack on titan both involve young
heroes striving to lead the trapped
human race towards a breakthrough
against seemingly infallible forces yes
they both deal with loss and tragedy as
a strong catalyst to move the plot
forward however the cool thing about
Gurren Lagann is that it carries itself
in a unique way with trigger signature
art style and over-the-top action in
terms of delivery and tone gurren lagaan
is completely the opposite of attack on
titan this type of excellent execution
on a generic theme and setup is a reason
why gurren lagaan has soared high above
the previous entries on the list and
turned into the fan favorite that it is
today
[Music]
[Music]
Monda sort of this might be a surprise
entry but fourth on the list is Arjun
this series is set in a world with
superhumans known as our jib these are
people who've risen from the dead and
have seemingly attained immortality
these daily humans are feared and are
labeled a threat to mankind of course
none of this is relevant to Kaine the
guy a student studying to become a great
doctor he suffers an accident that would
have killed him but instead of getting
sent off to another world with the
godlike powers to cheat the rules and
make all the girls fall in love with him
kay instead discovers that he's been
reborn as an Arjun thus begins his life
on the run allegiances are tested and
Kay starts his quest to find another
Arjun in the world yes I know a lot of
you are probably thinking it's CGI so
it's probably gonna be trash but trust
me you don't want to skip this one trust
me it's one of the better CGI anime I've
seen and I've got used to it after just
watching a few episodes just like attack
on Titan Argent's concept is of monsters
hiding among men both are also set in a
dark and morally ambiguous world for the
violence Arjun also tackles the idea of
the government trying to capture the
main character that's yet to come to
terms with his identity as one of the
monsters
mercy Beach number three on our list is
Claymore Claymore set in a world with
demons called youma gifted with the
ability to shape-shift the youma hide
among humans and await the opportunity
to feast on their defenseless prey after
losing his family to a youma Rocky's
saved by a stoic woman named Claire
she's a claim or a human youma hybrid
that specializes in tracking down the
shape-shifting demons left with no
family and nowhere to go after the
attack
rocky follows Claire on her journey
Claymore drops us in a world where
shape-shifting demons constantly
threaten humans the ones who stand in
the way of those demons are human demon
hybrids sounds a lot like how Titans are
dealt with in the case of Aaron right
adding to the similarities is the shared
goal of our protagonists both Aaron and
Claire are fueled by revenge
[Music]
[Applause]
second on the list is another show
that's carved its name amongst the
legends of the anime history Neon
Genesis Evangelion at this point a lot
of you are probably acquainted with the
iconic story of shinji ray oscar and the
rest of nerve after cataclysm wipes out
a chunk of the Earth's population
fourteen-year-old shinji ikari 'he's
summoned to pilot a robot called an
Evangelion his mission defend the earth
against alien beings called angels with
his copilot Shinji begins his journey as
he's thrown into the midst of the
conflict between humanity and angels
while attack on Titan focuses more on
the horror survival aspect even galleon
goes off and places more emphasis on
psychological aspects not to mention the
drastic differences between the
protagonists Aaron and Shinji are as
different as people can be still
Evangelion is one of the most iconic
shows in the history of anime for a
reason this is a show that deserves to
find its way to everyone's watchlist
maybe the original series or the movie
adaptations
[Music]
finally standing on top of everyone in a
list of shows like attack on Titan is
parasite one night strange alien
creatures descend to earth in the form
of spores these take over human hosts by
entering their brains whilst killing the
victim the parasites take over turning
the human into a killing machine with an
appetite for humans this seems to be a
completely flawless strategy for a
takeover but one parasite niggy fails
genichi the attended host manages to
prevent McGee from travelling further
into his brain and taking over resulting
in the parasite only manifesting in his
right hand
retaining their individual personalities
as Shinichi and a McGee must learn to
form a bond and work together in order
to survive in this new world filled with
man-eating monsters more than anything
parasite does that monsters living
alongside humans angle of attack on
Titan the best just like how the most
unsuspicious human turns out to be
Titans
there's virtually no way to immediately
distinguish an ordinary person from
someone who's been infected by a
parasite both shows also star a main
character that becomes involved with the
said alien species to his disdain just
like attack on Titan parasite tackles a
number of moral issues regarding the
concept of monsters in the human psyche
while one can figure out the
environmentalist undertones in parasite
with little effort further watching
would push the viewer towards the
questions that beg to ask whether humans
are the real monsters or not filled with
a lot of action suspense and themes that
make you think of this exciting horror
thrillers one not to be missed
that's it for this video if you find
something else that has substantial
similarities to attack on Titan and
would like to recommend it please feel
free to chime in on the comments section
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
to the channel if you haven't already
for more anime content I'll see you next
time on vinnie tube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]